foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
it's indictment day
apparently Donald Trump attorney's just
been told
yes in fact
Donald Trump should be
expected to be indicted
for charges related to January 6. the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup attempt of
course
again this isn't a big surprise we just
we just been trying to figure out like
what day what time when
it could possibly come today tomorrow
over the weekend
it's kind of hard to tell the grand jury
has been convened apparently
they were the grand jury was seen going
into the courthouse
Trump's attorneys went in to speak to
Jack Smith I would reckon it was because
Jack Smith looked at them and said hey
your client is [__]
in his [__]
I would say that's what they're probably
telling him
the attorneys if you want to call them
that I'm not sure what attorneys it was
but it doesn't really matter at this
point
again I I know a lot of people are
excited about indictment day that it's
finally here and we want to celebrate it
as like a Federal holiday right
you know everyone dies right we're all
mortal
what do you think there is more
celebration in the streets of this
country
When Donald Trump finally kicks the
bucket
then when Barack Obama went and and
killed or excuse me Osama bin Laden
what do you think
you think there'd be more celebrations
more people chanting USA holding the
flag now finally taking back our Banner
of freedom and liberty instead of this
fake ass patriotism [__] huh you think
I don't know I mean I guess that's a
pretty good question that history may
tell
the answer to
oh
I don't know because I I really I it's
as important as the in these indictments
are
because I don't want a discount
bringing federal felony charges against
the former president United States for
trying to commit a coup
it seems important
I don't know it seems important to me to
you yeah probably important
but it doesn't change
anything about the race other than it's
going to give him wind in his sales
which is
a wild wild thing
it's insanity
it's complete Insanity
to think
that more indictments of him overturning
our government trying to commit a coup
so that he can be the dictator the
authoritarian
the USA
that Patriots quote unquote Patriots
would simply stand back and let him just
wipe his ass with the Constitution
it doesn't make any sense but it's not
supposed to make sense
it's not supposed to make sense
and it won't make sense like when we get
all the facts because I know there's
things we don't know yet
there are things that Mark Meadows knows
that he's going to testify to
that he's probably given handed over
evidence and documentation to that we
don't know
and if Grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto
dust cue in honor Donald
Jessica Trump himself
gets on the stand and testifies and they
go to trial and it goes to a jury
decision
in the January 6 case
we're going to see
that evidence
will it change the minds of Maga I I
don't know
I don't know I don't think it probably
will for a small percentage of them at
least
and I keep preparing the audience I keep
preparing the nation
that don't get too excited about a trial
and the doj saving our country that's
not their job
Jack Smith's job is not to save our
democracy
it's for Law and Order it's to prosecute
crimes
one of those crimes is trying to
overthrow a government that that's a
crime
just ask Stuart Rhodes and Enrique tario
the leaders of The Oath Keepers and the
proud boys go ask them
go ask them when the Department of
Justice prosecutes you for trying to
overthrow our government what happens
well we'll today be the day
that Donald Trump is finally finding out
because he [__] around
I don't know
if today's the day for indictment
but when these indictments drop right
even when we know the charges and how
many charges and how many felonies
because that's going to give us a clue
into where Jack Smith is going with this
prosecution for January 6th
we could be highly disappointed
we could be highly disappointed they
could charge him think about it they
could charge him with just the
obstruction the obstruction of official
proceeding and wire fraud
two charges
maybe four or five in that same Realm
you're like wait a second where's the
seditious conspiracy
it's possible that they don't have that
so I I urge you I urge you I the
indictments are coming
we know that
he committed crimes
not just on January 6 but in the lead up
to the election
night
and on into January 6 and it the criming
got more and more intense
as he got more and more desperate to
hang on to power
and why in the world he was so scared to
let go of power
is beyond me maybe we'll find that out
too
maybe we'll find out that he was
protecting his own ass
trying to remain president so he
couldn't be prosecuted for I don't know
maybe trying to trying to collude with
Russia in the 2016 election
maybe crimes that he committed when he
was trying to get Ukraine to to fakely
prosecute Joe and Hunter Biden which
didn't work which got him impeached the
first time
I don't know
I bet Mark Meadows knows
if there's someone who knows it's
probably Mark Meadows
yesterday Mark Meadows was spotted and
there's audio of it I I why listen Audi
I think there's tape of it too
but I'm not even gonna show it because I
mean the only thing significant about it
is Mark Meadow said he's not going to
take any questions on anything j6
related
which is a huge tell
meaning Mark Meadows has been advised
not just by his lawyers but probably by
the special counsel don't
let it leave your lips [__]
and Mark Meadows is probably taking
legal advice unlike Donald Trump
we know Trump doesn't take legal advice
at all
I mean they probably give it to him over
and over and he gets really shitty legal
advice sometimes too so the only legal
advice he really takes is the [__] he
likes to hear
that's it we know that
that's why he's in the situation that
he's in in the documents case
it's why he's in the situation he's in
for January 6th Jesus Christ I showed
you a video yesterday of someone
reporting about John Eastman the the
architect of j6
the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
that John Eastman's like oh no we were
just floating ideas
we were just we were just brainstorming
coups we weren't actually queuing
there's a difference
so we know there's then
but we'll see we'll see who gets
indicted with him along along those
lines
but I wouldn't get too too excited yet
I know I'm trying to pop your balloon
but look
we know he's a criminal
we know a lot of the [__] that he did on
January 6 already we already know this
stuff the American people already know
because of the January 6 select
committee now there are some things I
believe deep down dark inside Mark
Meadows brains and notes and cell phone
that we don't know
because he was standing right next to
that fat slob the whole time
Jesus Christ everyone who wanted him to
call off the coup was calling and
texting Mark Meadows because they knew
he was standing right next to him
foreign
but don't
don't
get your hopes up
we have to engage in our democracy
Jack Smith the Department of Justice
Merrick Garland
are not going to save your democracy for
you
it is up to you you
yes you
they're not going to do it for us it
isn't their job
it is our job to engage in our democracy
and save it
if Jack Smith goes to trial on the
documents case
and and this January 6th case before the
election and they convict him and put
him in prison
I'll be wrong fantastic
how great would it for me to be wrong in
both those cases
it would be fantastic if I was
absolutely dead wrong
I don't think I'm going to be this is
just I I'm looking at the situation
I'm looking at the facts I'm looking at
timelines of how federal prosecutions
work
and I'm just convinced that there's no
way
not one chance in hell
that Donald Trump is going to go on
trial for anything
until after the election
and every day counts for our democracy
now every day counts and you engaging
now is more than more important tomorrow
than it is today and the next day and
the day after
we cannot waste time
yes you have your daily life you have
the things you have to do
but you come here you listen to this
show that's one way to engage
making phone calls writing letters
sending postcards making text messages
knocking doors eventually finding those
candidates to support registering voters
there's going to be nothing more
important than piling votes on top of
these fascist [__]
who want to who want to overturn our
governments and turn them into
authoritarian
bastions like Florida
so what are you going to do are you
going to focus on a trial that may not
happen and get your hopes up oh man oh
I'm so excited I mean I'm Gonna Get You
hyped up about it you don't have to
worry about getting hyped about it
I'm Gonna Get You hyped about
indictments I'm Gonna Get You hyped
about felony charges against Donald
Trump
I'm Gonna Get You hyped to beat his ass
when we get to the general election
and to absolutely pile him under
mountains of votes
I'm committed to doing that
no matter what the consequence I'm going
to commit
to making sure that the national
narrative and National messaging is on
Pace
and there's nothing there's nothing I
may not say
there's nothing I may not say to keep us
from winning
the pro-democracy coalition
you goddamn right
and I'll turn up my mic volume as loud
as it can go you can count on it
spread the word for crying out loud
but it is you
it is you
the voter with the power of your ballot
ballot and the power of your ability to
engage however that may be
to make sure that Donald Trump is
stuffed in the trash can
of History
as a twice impeached [__] loser
The Biggest Loser the worst president in
our history
that is your job
however your talents will lead you to
engage in your democracy
no Talent too small
no engagement too small
remember
Jack Smith Isn't Our Savior
he's not he won't be
he can't be our savior
we are the people
in that document that they all like to
hear I'm a patriot he says we the people
in there right here even though they're
against the people
they're they're for the authoritarian
governments
therefore the authoritarian police
they're for a police state they're for a
state that will tell you what you can
and cannot do who you can and cannot
love who you can and cannot marry what
you can and can how you can and cannot
dress
rather you can use contraception rather
you're banned from receiving your health
care because you're a woman
you don't you think they're going to
stop there no
they want to keep going
and Trump is only the vehicle that leads
them to their constituency to being the
worst versions of themselves which
allows them to keep this fascism
snowball rolling down the hill we must
stand in their way
and the way we do that is democracy
Liberty equality equity
is it hard you [__] ain't right it's
hard liberalism is the is the foundation
of strength
that's one thing I get sick and [__]
tired of hearing that Liberals are weak
that liberalism is weak you don't know
what liberalism is if you think it's
[__] weak
you're a [__] bonehead if you think
liberalism is weak just look at sag just
look at the writer's strikes
those people are gonna fight until they
get what they deserve UPS was willing to
strike to get what they deserve [__]
them [__] ups
those workers deserve their share
of profits for the trade of their labor
that is how it [__] works in this
country and if you don't like it [__]
you
that's the strength of liberalism
you think you think trying to put
together policy in this country where
that puts the majority of people in a
better position is easy
no no policy isn't [__] easy
policy is difficult that's why they want
an authoritarian figure
because they don't want to do policy
that's not what they want they want
theocracy
they're white Christian nationalists
they're Nazis
they want to just say this is the way it
is and we don't care what you think and
we don't care what reason we have to do
to do it it just is that and hate and
cruelty are a feature
go down to go down to the border at the
river
let's let's find out how many families
women and children
that Texans chip Roy you piece of
[__] trash standing up this morning
basically saying I support Greg Abbott
drowning families in the river
because I hate brown people they're a
threat to our white Nation chip Roy you
racist [__]
people of other religions Creeds color
backgrounds they're what makes our
country
they built this country for you to stand
up and spew your racism into a
microphone
and that District in Texas should be
ashamed of themselves today that you're
their [__] Representatives but
they're not because the cruelty is the
point folks Trump gives them the
permission to be the worst version of
themselves
it's a cult he's the cult leader
and the cult is well we'll just do and
say anything that's even murder even
murder and kill women and children at
the border with snagging drowns we'll
drown them in the river if we have to to
piss off liberals
oh boy that sounds that sounds like the
beacon the strength to me
the [__] out of here
we're smarter than this
oh well you're just getting a lot of
bunch of miscreants across the border
listen we're we're better than that
the miscreants that do get across the
border because there are some there are
a few a handful
we are better at making sure that those
miscreants don't [__] with our society
but women and children
chip Roy Greg Abbott you pieces of
[__] trash
you think women and children
should be drowned in the you know what
you know what Greg Abbott why don't you
just set up snipers why don't you just
do that just get it over with
do what you want to do and murder these
people
just do it
quit quit [__] around and do it
you're headed in that direction anyways
Jesus Christ you're willing to take it
all the way to the Supreme Court to
prove that you have the right to [__]
execute people on the border because
they're brown and they're Crossing an
imaginary [__] line that isn't your
line by the way it's not yours it's ours
it's ours [__]
that's a border of the United States of
America
and we are the people we are the
government It Is Us
and if you if you are thinking that
trumpism has nothing to do with this
you do not have enough brain cells to
rub together
he has given them permission to do this
when in the [__] in our recent timeline
have we been able to stand back and go
whoa whoa whoa they're drowning women
and children intentionally
they're setting up traps for them to be
drowned in the river and then if they
meet make it past the snag and drowns
they got razor wire on the on the banks
so that they have to pass little babies
through the razor wire
babies
little babies infants you know those
murderers and rapists babies
save the children right
the same people
supporting supporting the stupid [__]
Q Anon movie
are the same [__]
who are advocating for children to be
drowned at the Border in the river
because they all save the children just
not the brown ones
they don't really mean save the children
they don't mean that they don't mean
they want freedom they don't mean that
they when they say they're Patriots they
don't they don't [__] mean that
they're not no [__] Patriot
when they say they love our country they
don't love our country
they love what our country used to be at
one point in the history that they want
a cherry pick
that's what they [__] mean
they love their little white town and
they want it to stay white just like at
Jason Aldean and his stupid [__] song
that's what they mean that's what they
want
I've got a video to show you
it's like a two-year-old video
I'm gonna show you it's like a six
minute video today it's like six minutes
I think
it's Tyler Childers we had Tennessee
Brando on uh Monday Monday yeah Monday
and he talked about a video that Tyler
Childers did
I found it
we're going to show it
it's incredible it was two years ago two
[__] years ago
and it almost sounds like Tyler made
this video yesterday
in a rebuttal
to Jason Aldean and his stupid [__]
song about lynching and Sundown towns
that's what it is
it's the same [__] why they're drowning
children at the border it's the same
thing
and today we're going to worry about
some [__] fat slob down in Florida
getting indicted for the third [__]
time
I'm telling you
use this indictment only to politicize
to engage in our democracy to save it
don't count on this indictment saving us
you have to save us
that's why you come here every [__]
weekday
is to understand why
why we must engage
why what are they doing how are they
trying to to take this away from us
this isn't about indictments
this isn't about each and every crime
that Trump and his allies have committed
this is about the broad scope
of how they're trying to chip away at
our democracy so when we lose it we
never thought we had it in the first
place
so are you going to take a stand
will you with me
and engage in your democracy Point your
strategic outrage in the place that it
needs to be pointed
do the work that the ballot allows us to
do
will you do that
if you will you're in the right place
if you know someone else out there that
is the same mind as you they need to
come to this place
now I'm not going to set this microphone
down
and we're gonna get louder
we're gonna get prouder it's gonna get
bigger there's gonna be more every
single day come here and listen to me
scream and yell the f word whether you
like it or not
it will be something
we've got I don't know we got several
months until the election
we can make this happen
and I'm counting on you because your
action
will save this country we'll save this
democracy we'll save our Republic
it will bring us to a place
Where We the People
can collectively as a as a liberal
democracy
figure out a way to deliver equality and
Equity as close as we possibly can get
for all
it won't be easy it's gonna be hard
[__] work and it's going to be much
longer past this election and much
longer past this indictment and the
trial and Donald Trump's ultimate demise
we will have to work even after that fat
slob is gone away from this Earth we
will still fight
and stand with democracy
so you ready
it's a long commitment it's several
decades I know you're like God damn Tony
wants us to say we'll do it for 20 years
you goddamn right I want to
20 30 40 however long it takes
probably won't end would be my guess
ideas like fascism don't die they just
hide under rocks
to later show themselves
as the evil they truly are make sure
that you hit the like button down below
and subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
you can also watch us on Facebook
if you're on the books of face right now
or if you have a Facebook account just
follow us at the Tony Michaels you can
watch live there every day like I said
you can watch on Twitch too it's free to
follow us over there twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels also if you have your
Amazon account tied to your Twitch
account you got it linked don't forget
to re-subscribe
very very important for you to
resubscribe you got to do it every month
if you want us to get that couple bucks
that Amazon gives us you got to
re-subscribe if you need directions on
how to resubscribe go to
thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com you can find the link
there's the fourth one down it says link
Amazon and prime it gives you the
directions on how to link them and how
to resubscribe so go find that at
d20michaels.com while I'm talking about
the Tony michaels.com you need to check
out patreon and really you need to I
think I'm gonna make a playlist on
YouTube for these Round Table of
democracies that we're doing on patreon
what we're doing let me give you a quick
rundown speaking of engaging in your
democracy
I always say engage in your democracy I
said it I don't know did I how many
times I say it a million
I think I've said it about a million
times I'll say it a million more but
here's the thing not just listen to me
go engaging in your democracy what we're
going to do is try to put the tools
together for you to do it I did a video
we did a workshop type thing where I
just went through a website called
fivecalls.org that's fivecall.org that
video is on the YouTube channel live
right now as a round table of democracy
we did it on patreon and when we do
these on patreon our patreon members are
all going to get together and we're
gonna we're gonna develop these
workshops and these round tables
together and then we're gonna present
them to you the audience if you're not a
member of patreon if you want to
participate come on over to patreon go
to the Tony michaels.com check out the
patreon page you guys will be able to
participate help engage help plan I'm
going to do a couple planning meetings
this weekend because we got Nick O'Neal
Nick O'Neill is the founder he's one of
the founders of
fivecalls.org that's right I got the
founder he wants to come on the show and
he wants to help you do a workshop to
explain his website and why it's so
important to make these phone calls even
more really cool website it's a really
cool concept it's a really easy concept
you can do it by by your representatives
or you can do it by topic it's really
really cool it's a great resource but
most people don't know it exists or
don't know how to use it so we're gonna
have Nick come on the show talk about
fivecalls.org probably next week
sometime and we're going to do a
workshop with him where he explains to
us the best way to navigate his website
we did a navigation video I also have
Jess Piper she wants to come on and
talking about engaging with elected
officials with education we're going to
do a workshop with her soon too all that
to come so this weekend we're going to
do a couple planning uh uh meetings on
patreons to go to the Tony michaels.com
check out the patreon page there but if
you're not if you don't don't worry if
you can't afford a patreon no problem
all this content will be be provided to
you for free right here on the YouTube
channel we'll put all the workshops up
it's different it's not me ranting it's
you learning how to engage giving you
the tools to do what I'd say go engage
and you're like oh yeah well how do I do
that Tony here's the tools I'm going to
find all the people we're going to
gather up all the people next 18 months
put them all together so you know how to
engage so you can find the way that you
can engage easiest that makes you most
comfortable that's the point of the
Roundtable democracy don't go anywhere
I got some clips to show you I wanted to
show you this Tyler Childers video it's
kind of long but we're going to show it
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right back
right after these messages
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
looking around through the brakes oh the
Trump fun he's gonna need a hell of a
lot more money isn't he
or all the attorneys he's gonna have to
pay for I don't know I don't know if we
have indictments yet and we're getting
close we're getting close probably
sometime this afternoon I think it'll
actually be announced this afternoon
that it's under sealed but he is
indicted
um I I believe that the Trump attorneys
have been notified that that's what the
reporting is that the Trump attorneys
have been notified that he is going to
be indicted apparently the grand jury is
set to meet today and which only
indicates that Jack Smith is making the
move to get them to vote for indictment
um and we'll see exactly how that comes
down as and my guess is that it will be
reported as a sealed indictment because
they won't actually unseal it more than
likely until the arraignment like we've
seen with the last one now we'll we'll
be able to pause we'll be able to make
predictions of what these charges are
more than likely because that will
probably be given to the Press too
by Trump
uh not know that these leaks that come
to the Press are by Trump and his team
because I I would gather that the the
attorneys for Donald Trump this morning
when they met with Jack Smith as a
special counsel my guess is that they
were told more than likely What charges
they're going to present to the grand
jury they were given four days last week
was it something like that when you
received the uh the target letter to
come in and and give his side of the
story of course he's not going to do
that and the reason why is because he's
guilty as [__]
just how that works
um and and no real true defendant who
wants to defend themselves in court not
make a deal uh would actually come in
and speak to the grand jury or to the
special counsel
that's just how it goes now if you're
trying to avoid a trial if you're trying
to avoid a prosecution if you're trying
to avoid indictment you probably would
but this guy's not he's not trying to
avoid indictments Jesus Christ he's
already got [__] 70 some felonies it
won't really 90 some if you can if you
include the 17
that he was convicted on Trump
organization was convicted on in the
state of New York for [__] fraud
so the the felonies stack up against
this son of a [__]
and there's going to be more and more
felonies now again I don't again
I I know it's exciting to talk about the
indictment and it's sexy right like this
is big news like yeah Jack Smith's doing
the thing right we've been waiting for
this for a long time but the thing is is
the indictment is only going to produce
what an arraignment and the
arraignment's only going to produce
other motions those motions are going to
produce maybe a trial and and that that
may not be the trial they're going to
punt the trial so so I mean don't get
too [__] excited yet this is not over
okay this is just the [__] beginning
of this [__]
there's a hell of a lot of things that
we're gonna have to walk through to get
to Donald Trump actually getting his ass
in a prison cell or incarcerated because
I you know I have a hard time believing
that a federal judge is going to lock up
a former president in a federal prison I
really have a hard time believing it
and the reason why is because I'm trying
to reach an expectation in my brain that
allows me to go well that's not so
surprising
right
are you at least you should be
I don't know kind of uh under promise
over deliver for myself and that's what
I'm trying to do for you I'm not trying
to to discourage you
I'm not trying to get your hopes up down
or or be all doom and gloom but the
point is to be realistic about this to
be realistic about the work we have to
we have to do against this [__] idiot
and against his Maga cult
we got work to do
Jack Smith will do his work we should do
ours that's the way I look at it here
and we should use Jack Smith's work to
do ours we should politicize the [__]
out of Jack Smith's work you goddamn
right we should
I mean I can't believe that Ron DeSantis
isn't taking advantage of this I knew he
wouldn't because he's a [__] ass [__]
Ron DeSantis is a flaccid weirdo
and I knew that from the very beginning
I knew Ron DeSantis would be a Scott
Walker right
carrying a [__] Nazi flag that's
basically what Rhonda Santos is
he's he's gonna he's gonna fade out
quicker than a goddamn bottle rocket
it's gonna happen I told you it would
and it will
listen I know it's like how does he know
some of this [__] but it's only because
I've been watching politics for so long
I've been paying attention I know the
[__] recent history
and I figured out how Colts work
it's not hard to see
so don't get too ex I mean get excited
about indictment day hell yeah go rub it
in people's faces politicize the [__]
out of it
but don't let it make you sit back and
think that someone else is going to do
the work for us that's all I'm asking
that's all I'm asking
and don't [__] on the work of that
Merrick Garland and and Jack Smith have
done to this point
oh man these [__] Garland haters
go [__] in their cereal go [__] in the
Merrick Garland uh uh haters cereal this
morning oh Merrick Garland
garlands go he's never gonna charge
Trump they're not going to drive Trump
for January 6. oh my God it's been this
long it's been a long time blood bloody
yakety smackity [__] do no shut the
[__] up you [__] hating [__]
they've been doing the work man they've
been doing the work
you're gonna [__] around and find out
and I hope all those who were hating on
on [__] Merit Garland and Jack Smith
can finally can finally stand there and
say okay I was wrong I was wrong because
I man I'll I'll say it when I'm wrong
you know I will I'll say it when I'm
wrong if Donald Trump goes to trial
before the election I'll say God Damn I
I'm glad I'm wrong
but that's the difference is when I'm I
try to when I try to be wrong I try to
be like oh though that's better than
being right
again
under promise over deliver
that's the most beautiful part
so I wouldn't get uh too excited about
him being in an orange jumpsuit I don't
know maybe this federal judge will will
uh detain him it's possible they could a
federal judge can defend detain a
defendant they detain Stewart Rhodes
they detained uh Enrique atario so I
guess it just I guess
I guess it just depends
on What charges
he is indicted on so all right all right
um um someone's asking for the link to
Tony's five call Workshop go go to the
YouTube channel
that's where you go go the YouTube
channel
the Tony Michaels podcast
that's where you go the Tony Michaels
podcast at the very top of it
there's a there's a little there's Tabs
go to the live tab
go to the live tab you'll find phone a
bonehead that's it I'm gonna make a
playlist and really honestly when we
when we finally come up with a name for
the Roundtable democracy that's what
we're calling it it sounds like that's
what we're going to call it is the
Roundtable democracy and because it just
it works so well but we're probably
going to open up some sort of website to
where there's links and stuff to find
this stuff easier that's my goal I I
mean I want it easy for you guys to find
so so the patreon uh uh folks the
members of patreon are going to help
develop all this stuff they're going to
help get ideas get people going I've
gotten so many messages and thank you to
all the people out there you I I want to
thank you for sending me so many
messages for so many great ideas of
workshops that you want to do and even
if you're not on patreon you can try to
send me messages but it's easiest if you
go to patreon because you can DM me on
on patreon if you're a patreon member
but if you can't afford it don't worry
about it don't worry don't worry it's
okay it's okay you will still get to see
the con content you will still get to
see the workshops
but the patreon members are helping
everyone we're working kind of as a
group to figure out how we want and what
workshops we want what stuff they want
because I'm just kind of the outlet
right like I just have the ability to do
the software and bring the people and I
mean I've got the platform and the
influence I should use it and I tell you
guys to engage I just never gave you the
tool so here we are one of the most
important elections of our lifetime I
might as well use my abilities that I
have to give you not just the
encouragement and the Strategic outrage
but also give you the tools to go engage
in your democracy with that strategic
outrage that's most important speaking
of strategic Outreach we Act
I wish I could have avoided this uh
Jason Aldean [__] I wish he would just
go into the trash bin of History already
just get it over with he's going to but
the point is this is that this Jason
Aldean song in the in in the the overt
racism in the [__] video and and his
stupid [__] crybaby whining I got
canceled [__] just continues uh because
[__] the Bud Light Barbie Army
huh can't shut their [__] racist
traps but I found we had Tennessee
Brando on Monday
and he talked about an artist called
Tyler Childers who is an artist and he's
putting out a new album
um this week which is kind of it's just
a coincidence I didn't do this on
purpose
yeah just just kind of [__] just happens
sometimes but he's putting out an album
this week a new song and it's about uh
two gay coal miners I mean he's singing
about them and I haven't listened to all
the song yet just part of it seems like
a pretty good song but the thing is is
that Tennessee Brando talked about on
Monday you heard him talk about that he
did a response to a video that Tyler put
out two years ago and that was really
what kind of got Tennessee Brando in the
political sphere
right got him writing some of these
political songs right
and the reason why is because uh Tyler
was
rebuking the same kind of sentiment that
is in the Jason Aldean song oh don't be
doing rats in our small town as if
anyone would go to a small town we
listened to uh Trey Crowder the other
day like who the [__] is gonna go to a
small town who the [__] is gonna go to
Buck snork Tennessee is what uh
that's how he put it in his joke and
Troy Crowder
um who the [__] is gonna go there and
antifa's not going there to change
change the minds of people okay just not
they're not a threat to you in Buck
snort that was the joke that Trey made
but this video here from Tyler is much
more serious
and it is the video that Tennessee
Brando said that he gave a response to
um and I think it's important to show
this uh Chris Christopher Webb
on Twitter uh posted this video just
just a little bit ago in its full form
it's about just over six minutes I want
to play the whole thing for you and the
reason why is because this is a rebuttal
to Jason Aldean before Jason Aldean
wrote his song and recorded that racist
ass video and whined and complained that
people thought it was racist because it
is
and the reason why it works the reason
why this Tyler
chillers video works so well as a
rebuttal
is because racism is so [__]
antiquated
it's so Antiquated you could pull out a
hundred videos to rebut Jason Aldean and
his dumb [__] song
and you could do it just in the simple
genre a country music and country music
artist
damn right you could
you could pull it out all over the place
because racism is dumb it's delusional
it's the most ridiculous [__] thing
and the most ridiculous institution that
we still [__] Cowtown to in this
stupid ass country of ours where we do
this stupid narrative on this [__]
but Tyler did such a good video out
remember
when you hear this you're gonna go whoa
he's talking about Jason Aldean he's
talking about that song
but he's not
he's not
he's not talking about that song
because this video is two years old so
there's no way he would have known it so
here here's the video I'm from Tyler
back in June when I wrote the song Long
violent history it was my original goal
to continue to make fairly legible
sounds on the fiddle and put this album
out with no announcements of press
I plan to package it as an old-time
fiddle album and let the piece make its
statement on its own taking listener by
surprise at the end
however there has been concern that the
album could run the risk of being
misinterpreted if not given some sort of
accompanying explanation to set it in
context
a writer can write an essay but the
writer can never predict or control how
that essay is interpreted by the reader
be it in a tone of level-headed calmness
or preachy holier than thou
condescending way
as recovering alcoholic who is drunk and
drugged himself around the world playing
music for the better part of 11 years
and now has six months of sobriety I can
say with clarity
that I have no soapbox to stand on to
talk preachy to anyone on anything be it
the word of God or the condition of the
world
but as a person who has been given a
platform
by Providence luck support and working
at it I feel undeserving of the grace
this world has given me and I would find
it a waste where I'm out to try and use
it to make some good
long violent history is a collection of
instrumental pieces intended to create a
Sonic soundscape For The Listener to set
the tone to reflect on the last track
which is my own observational piece on
times we are in
covet has been a strain on all of us in
some form or fashion people have been
cooped up and quarantined
people have lost their jobs and are
struggling to make ends meet
people have lost their family members
the country is feeling a general angst
all the while we've all witnessed
violent acts of police brutality happen
around the nation that have gone
unaddressed
in response we've seen protests turn to
riots and riots culminate in acts of
violence and destruction property
from the outsider's perspective it's
hard to see where all this visceral
anger is coming from
what I believe to be one of the biggest
obstacles in pinpointing the cause of
this is our inability to empathize with
another individual or groups plight
in the midst of our own daily struggles
it's often hard to share an
understanding for what another person
might be going through
with that in mind that the risk of
mistakenly analogizing two groups of
people
I would ask my white rural listeners to
think on this
I don't mean to imply that many of you
aren't already doing good
self-examination on this issue but I
have heard from many who have not
what if we were to constantly open up
our daily paper and see a headline like
East Kentucky man shot seven times on
fishing trip right on to find the man
was shot while fishing with his son by a
game warden who saw him rummaging
through his tackle box for his license
and thought he was reaching for a knife
what if we read a story that began North
Carolina man rushing home from work to
take his elderly mother to the ER run
stop sign is pulled over and beaten by
police when they see a gun rack in the
truck
or a headline like Ashland Community and
Technical College nursing student shot
in her sleep
how would we react to that
what form of upheaval would that create
I venture to say if we were met with
this type of daily attack on our own
people we would take action in a way
that hasn't been seen since the Battle
of Blair mountain in West Virginia
and if we want to stand for it
why would we expect another group of
Americans to stand for it
while we stay in silent while that
happened or Worse get in the way of it
being rectified
I've heard people from my Appalachian
region say that we want to act the way
we've seen depicted on various media
Outlets
but I've also seen Grown Folks beat each
other up the day after Thanksgiving for
TVs and teddy bears and these aren't
things this community has lost these are
sons and daughters
brothers and sisters and cousins mothers
and fathers
Irreplaceable threads within their
family fiber torn from their loved ones
too soon with no justice and they are
demanding change
same as I expect we would
life is hard enough without being
worried about the smallest interaction
with a public servant
so what can the rest of us who feel
seemingly outside of these issues do
first we can use our voting power to get
rid of the people that have been in
power and let this go unnoticed chances
are the people allowing this to happen
are the same people keeping opportunity
Out Of Reach for our own communities
that have watched job opportunities
shipped out
and Drug shipped in eating up our
communities and leaving our people
desperate and while some folks would
deem a food desert
we can stop being so taken aback by
black lives matter
if we didn't need to be reminded there
would be Justice for Brianna Taylor a
Kentuckian like me and countless others
we can start looking for ways to
preserve Our Heritage outside lazily
defending a flag with history steeped in
racism and treason
things like human log carving a bowl
learning a fiddle tomb growing a garden
raising some animals canning our own
food hunting and processing the animal
fishing blacksmithing trapping and
Tanning to hide selling a quilt
and if we did things like that we'd have
a lot less time to argue back and forth
over things we don't fully know backed
by news we can't fully trust
love each other no exceptions and
remember united we stand divided we fall
so there is uh Travis Childers a lot of
people are asking who that is in the
chat uh excuse not Travis Tyler Tyler
Childers Tyler is a country music artist
he's a Bluegrass musician we were
talking to Tennessee Brando on Monday
and I I
very passionate about this that country
music is not rooted in racism and Tyler
does such a good job of breaking it down
there this is country music has its
roots in Folk
the Appalachia area of our country is
where the root of country music is
and country music is the art of the
plight of poor folk in Appalachia
and they should identify with the plight
of poor Folk
in other parts of the country people who
are being oppressed especially by
authoritarian government police force
we should understand this they should
understand this everyone should
understand this
it's not difficult to understand
and I think that Tyler does such a great
job
of breaking it down
in this video
this video is two years old
two years old
didn't it feel like he was doing a
rebuttal to Jason Aldean's song
cry later small town
and the reason why
the reason why it feels like a rebuttal
even though this video is two years old
it's because racism is much older than
two years
bigotry is much older than two years
this country is an institution of racism
bigotry
no matter how you shake it and Tyler
here is trying to shake it out of people
trying to tell them what would happen
What would happen if police came into
a house of a nursing student in your
town and murdered her
like they did Brianna Taylor what would
you do
what would you do if they were doing
this in your small town huh
what if they were trying that in a small
town huh
huh Jason
what would you do
would you stand back and let the
institution of racism and bigotry
dictate your authoritarian ways
you know it's funny
I was driving down the road the other
day
and it made me think of this stupid
[__] Jason Aldean song
I saw a Toyota
SUV that's right a Toyota SUV are you
following me so far a Toyota SUV
with a license plate on the back I live
in Missouri and you can get like
personalized license plates and [__]
right and you can get vanity plates or
you can get like uh you can get plates
from different organizations that
sponsor the plates that have like their
logo and [__] on it and you know you can
get like a license plate a frame right
and you can get bumper stickers to put
on your car this person had a license
plate that was a don't tread on me
license plate they had a license plate
frame that was a don't tread on me and
they had a [__] bumper sticker that
was a don't tread on me sticker on their
Toyota
okay
so not only did the don't tread on me
people like I hate government government
bad them credit on me
they went and bought a license plate
from a government agency because they
have to license their vehicle with the
tyrannical tread on them government
and they literally bought a [__]
license plate
it's [__] ridiculous
it's insanity
and I I would almost bet I would almost
bet if you went and
approached approached this uh person
that had this license plate just don't
tread on me I give them a Democrats bad
[Music]
I would almost bet
almost bit that this video that Tyler
put out would piss them off
because it's a damn good argument
against their bigotry damn good argument
it's the argument that I was trying to
make after the Jason Aldean song came
out
that's why I ended up being like you
know what I'm just gonna talk about it
[__] it I thought the Jason Aldean thing
would fade within hours because he's
such a [__] chucklehead he's not even
a good musician
he's not he's not even that great of a
singer and he's really [__] ugly what
do you want from me oh yeah Tony you're
calling him ugly well Hey listen if
you're a really shitty singer you don't
write your own music
you can't dance where the [__] you don't
put on a decent [__] show you better
be pretty
something right something Jesus Christ
have some Talent somewhere Jesus [__]
Christ Jason
you talentless [__]
the only reason why Jason Aldean is who
he is is because what Tennessee Brando
said on Monday they [__] they created
this bro country [__] this false
narrative in country music that isn't
real it's not a thing
it's it's stupid ridiculous and
delusional Tyler really tells you what
country music is about did you listen to
that video
that that is what country music is about
that's what Bluegrass is about that's
what folk music is about
not this [__] that Jason Aldean and
some of these other bro country artists
are singing it might be catchy it might
be cool but they're underlining
sentiment and some of their songs are
[__] racist and it's ignorance
just ignorant
can't put two thoughts to rub together
in these songs
but I think it's worth noting
that it's not the history of country
music it's not what country music is
about
it's not it really isn't
and nor do we have to have the narrative
that it is
there are folks in in poor areas in this
country rural areas that don't believe
the [__] that Jason Aldean is trying
to sell
a lot of them do
but at the heart of it they don't
they don't
they're Democrats they just don't know
it
and the only way to get them to get them
where we're at is to go where they are
and where they are is to the issues they
don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill just like you you don't
want to go broke because of a medical
bill
they want to have a decent [__] wage
they don't want to live in poverty their
entire [__] lives and their children
and grandchildren live in poverty their
entire lives because they can't pull
themselves up by their bootstraps
because it doesn't exist that's not a
[__] thing
you know what does work
us collectively as a liberal democracy
as a union
to say no you're not going to screw us
anymore we're trading our labor and
you're going to pay us fairly whether
you [__] like it or not we don't care
what we don't care what the minimum wage
is we don't give a [__] about any of
those policies that you're talking about
we don't care about the past we don't
give a [__] about about what you say it
is should and shouldn't be we want our
share that's what UPS did Jesus Christ
UPS oh man UPS avoided an economic
disaster no no
no the workers got paid what they're
worth
that's what happened
God damn it the workers got their share
[__] ups
[__] them
they're the one treading on you guy with
the tread don't tread on me license
plates
they're treading on you
you're the one
that can make the change
and the only way to make the change is
with democracy if you think autocracy is
the way you're you are going to make a
change you're a dumb son of a [__] you
are a dumb [__] if you're on the
side of the cops
and an authoritarian government
to to be part of change do you think
anyone in Florida feels like they're in
control of change when Ron DeSantis is
running around be like you know what
we're just going to teach that slavery
was good oh it taught him all kinds of
skills oh man let me kill you oh man it
made it made slaves in the blacksmiths
is what it did it gave them real hard
work and skills to get out there and be
somebody get the [__] out of here he
acts like there was only one generation
or a half a generation enslaved in this
country you piece of [__] trash
to act like the history of slavery or
some kind of [__] intense job
training [__] you [__] you and your
stupid whitewashed history you can go
get [__] and that's that's been the
[__] narrative everyone thinks that
that's new that's been the [__]
narrative in real white areas for a long
time for a long time it's been well it
wasn't that bad God damn they had three
Hots in a cot and they learned how to
blacksmith and [__]
that's always been their excuse
to excuse slavery
the biggest [__] stain
on our country
so don't get it twisted we got bonehead
of the week today I know I know you're
disappointed that we're not gonna have a
show tomorrow but it's okay it's okay
it's okay just one day just one day it's
just one day it's just one I promise
come back on Monday I know I may not be
here tomorrow and you're like Tony but
what if indictments don't come down
today what if they come down tomorrow
I've thought about this already God damn
it
what do you want from me
[Laughter]
I've already made these commitments
it's okay and the problem is is that I
can't do the show tomorrow Gabe can't do
the show tomorrow and it's only the two
of us when I yell and scream at like the
people over here again I told you
yesterday and there's not really anybody
it's just a wall see it's just a wall
there's no one really over there
there's no one over there it's it's just
me
it's just like right now it's just me
here Gabe's not even here yet he's gonna
be here soon he's working on bone end of
the week but we got bone in the week
we're gonna come up and Gabe's got a
heart out at the top of the hour so
we're gonna try to keep it tight we're
gonna try to keep the bone head tight
so we can get to the top of the air I
know everyone wants a three hour episode
today and I wanted to show you this
video from Tyler and I know there's all
kinds of indictment news blah blah blah
blah you know all that
[__] but don't don't go anywhere because
if indictments do drop on the show we're
gonna show them right here on the show
when we come back well we have bonehead
of the week will we have it okay he says
yes he says yeah we sort of kind of
maybe I don't know he says we got it all
right don't go anywhere right back after
this
bonehead of the week
[Music]
right back
mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show bound head of
the week I know it's Thursdays it
happens on Friday I don't know what to
tell you
[Music]
to cover it couldn't cover it but we're
gonna do bone end of the week either way
we weren't gonna let you not go
uh to the weekend without bonehead of
the week so we're gonna do Boone hey
of the week
right here on the economy Michaels
podcast uh Gabe Sanchez is joining us
there we go well maybe oh everything
I saw somebody your microphone your
microphone there we go I saw someone I
saw someone ask uh yeah hold on let me
see what they say uh
no no I need to know where you found
this binder Amazon Walmart Target where
I made it
he literally made it I literally I
literally went to the store I went to uh
a Michael's or another like craft store
and I got all of the materials and I
created it myself
that's pretty sweet and this was like
two years ago right
yeah I think so
I think it's been a while yeah yeah it
was it had been a couple years because I
had done it after I did my boycott Wall
video which is like every company that
Republicans were boycotting it which is
a printed logo on a wall right and the
guy going back and forth would be like
oh I uh
what about this thing like can't
boycotted what about this he's like
can't boycotted it was nice now you need
like four more you need like four more
walls yeah I could build a house out of
it right well I mean because you'd have
to have Barbie to have yeah like I mean
it just the list goes on and on there's
a ton I uh I mean you've seen in the
boycott binder Eminem's isn't even in
there no yeah this is before that it was
like before that I had I had okay I had
uh I had PornHub on there I had you know
I had wait wait wait wait wait a second
why were they boycotting PornHub because
I'm trying to remember PornHub did
something yeah during the pandemic must
be like the lgbtq thing because they do
like a pride month on there it might
have been I forget exactly what it was
but they did something and then what
happened was they're like oh we're
boycott PornHub and I'm like okay yeah
sure
okay wink just like your boycotting
grinder yeah right yeah right look yeah
you you do you okay right right oh yeah
sure sure you are yeah that's how it
goes have you heard the news someone's
gonna get indicted today possibly I
heard it uh his name is uh John Barron I
believe oh okay all right yeah all right
all right did he also do the presidency
at some point you know he was a go-to
guy when people needed to get Insider
information on what was happening I just
feel like
they're all one and the same right you
know Donald Trump John Barron what are
the other names that he came up with I
don't know this is random things just
random but yeah I I mean who knows maybe
like George Santos they'll be like
whatever his name is on the indictment
they'll just be like uh Donald Trump uh
John Barron and uh whatever the [__] he
goes by
other ways and just put it on there
they'll be like yeah you know the guy
known as Donald Trump whatever right why
I mean we're in bonehead the week so I'm
sure we're going to talk about this John
Baron again oh yeah of course of course
eventually well here's here's our
speaking of Barbie here's our uh uh
Barbie Shapiro is one of our boneheads
here I think that's what I'm gonna call
him for now on Barbie Shapiro why not
[__] him I mean yeah that's fine I'm
gonna call him uh I have a little bit
I'm uh I'm editing the video
for my what was that and it's all about
I dude this was I had to cut a ton of
content out of this video because it was
like eight pages worth of [__] yeah
that's how much you're gonna you're
gonna do like a a 30 hours what was that
yeah it was gonna be a long one so then
I had to cut a bunch of stuff and just
have like one one-line uh mentions it's
basically just a total video of me just
Clowning on Ben Shapiro but I mean you
could do like 30 like a 30 day stream
like straight through 24 hours a day of
nothing but clowning on adventure I'd be
like look we're on 85 right owning Ben
Shapiro and it's it's like where they're
like let's release the footage from the
capital January 6 and like look if you
had one person watching this from 24
hours a day taking like 547 years that
would be the that's how long it would
take you can't you can't tell me that
you saw all that footage shut the [__]
up you have not seen all the clowning
that you can see of Barbie do I do
believe that uh
he's called a Ben doll he's not a Ken
doll a Bend he's a Ben doll give me your
best give me your best Shapiro clip that
you want me to show since he's on the
bonehead here I don't have it yet I
haven't no no I no I mean the best one
that you that you think like on Twitter
or something and let's show the audience
why he's a bonehead for this yeah yeah
okay cause that's why he's on bone the
other week because of his obsession with
a little plastic doll
does he does he know that originally
Barbie was made for girls does he know
that I don't know man it's really hard
it's really hard to understand if anyone
knows what they're talking about anymore
it's funny though what's a woman crowd
can't figure out what's a Barbie like
like you guys you guys run around you
made a whole documentary on what is a
woman because you can't figure it out
like this is these are the same these
are the same yeah same people who are
freaking out because they're like oh no
no no no no you can't you can't have a
movie with a a Barbie doll
and the ability the the lack of
awareness uh but the ability to have
self-owned again and again and again
with Ben Shapiro and all these other
right-wing idiots is amazing right you
had
um yesterday I think we played a clip of
Nick Fuentes yes going on some
anti-semitic remark about the Barbie
movie yeah talk about Jewish something
like what the [__] about the inventor
is a Jewish woman is that what he's
saying is that what he's saying no no no
I think he's just trying well I don't
know if it's because they were she they
had the inventor in the movie right and
that's what but regardless anti-semitic
[__] he was saying not for it you got
Ted Cruz who's saying it's part of the
CCP plot whatever the [__] he's talking
about so so wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait so what you're telling me
is the CCP and the Jewish space lasers
are in coordination here with the Barbie
it's a full with the Barbie movie yeah
not only that but it's also the train
dance Community because Ben Shapiro was
very triggered by that as was Charlie
Kirk because it's some transphobic
propaganda or transphobia trans
propaganda he says it in a video where
he does an interview with like so this
is Hollywood trying to push on the trans
propaganda he got triggered Ted Cruz got
triggered Nick Fuentes got triggered
Ginger Gates got triggered she claimed
that she was an expert or rather at the
the Barbie that I knew when I was a kid
empowering men with women that's the
whole movie does is about that you can
and that's why that's why that's why
Barbie that's why Barbie Shapiro was so
pissed off because it empowers women
because they're like oh my God this
movie empowers Women we don't want that
like literally that's why they're mad at
a plastic doll but here's here's the
beginning of the video that kind of
sparked this whole camera this is how
this is really how he started the whole
43 minute video 43 minutes he I think
he's done two or three videos this week
just on Barbie yeah and and and the
length of the videos that he's done
bitching about the movie of Barbie are
longer than the [__] movie like
literally you could watch the movie and
the time that you can watch these
[__] stupid videos spent more and I
think the funniest part about this is
how much he complains about oh people
people didn't understand this was it was
a joke or it was just no no no no no no
no that's not why we're laughing we're
laughing at you because you're a [__]
[__] right you're laughing at you right
and we'll play the video and then I'll
explain the breakdown of the cost here
yeah sure let's so let's let's play this
video this is where Ben Shapiro
buys and burns Barbie dolls it's weird
but let's let's take a listen I'm gonna
give my review of the Barbie movie in
the most Oppenheimer fashion
what the [__]
[Applause]
I'm gonna get this is their attempt at
comedy Now I want to show you something
real quick here I'm gonna I'm gonna take
the volume off watch Ben Shapiro lights
a match like he holds Lumber hey I just
noticed that no I'm serious he likes a
match like he holds Lumber and if you
don't know the reference you just need
to go Google
Ben Shapiro Lumber and you'll know what
I'm talking about but here's here he
holds he lights a match like he holds
Lumber watch this when he lights the
match you see that
my little manicured hands
do you think do you think Ben Shapiro
Barbie Shapiro excuse me do you think
Barbie Shapiro uses more nail polish
than the average viewer at the Barbie
movie I think so I think for a guy that
said when he went to go see the movie
because in the video he was like I went
to the movie and it was a bunch of moms
young middle-aged moms with their seven
eight-year-old daughters and I'm like
dude you could have taken your daughters
to go see this right like I Can Only
Imagine
his kids being like Oh Dad can we go see
the move and he's like no actually uh I
gotta go to the movie to [__] own
these Lambs because I'm so [__]
emasculated like dude how many Barbies
how many more time with your family dude
how many Barbies do you think his
daughters actually own he's probably got
a whole [__] room with at least three
or four Barbie houses they got the cars
they got the helicopter they got tons
they got the whole [__] set
yeah he spent thousands and thousands of
dollars on having on having Barbie man
that [__] ain't cheap dude
read your Tweet here to show what was in
the video how much it costs all right so
this is not even everything so what I
said was Ben Shapiro paid almost 100 but
actually when I look at it he paid
almost 150 to own the lids in this
Barbie video so he had the Barbie
leopard doll which he threw in the trash
but missed that was 23 then there's
Barbie the doll from the movie that's 25
Ken Nadal from the movie that's 25 and
their little cheap drug that they're in
is twenty dollars now on top of that if
you look at the matches I looked at the
matches online it's like eight bucks you
look at the lighter fluid that he had to
put on there and that was probably 16 to
20 bucks let's say then he went to go
see the movie and he paid a child's
ticket is 9.75 so we'll just go with
that and then 10.75 forever the adult
was that chaperoned them so we're
looking at another 20 bucks wait are you
are you saying that Ben Shapiro bought a
child ticket for himself because he's
such a [__] child he didn't he
couldn't buy the ticket and the adult
who chaperone bought the ticket oh okay
the one who took the photo of him in the
lobby of the Cinemark and where he's
dressed up as Ken exactly right and that
one so that's like you know 20 bucks
right there you know for a child ticket
The Chaperone ticket I'm giving you a
little preview of what you're gonna see
in the what was that by the way that's
great so get ready but in this
he spends all of that and it's like a
hundred and forty two hundred forty
three dollars so almost 150 Ben Shapiro
owned the line these products he spends
a hundred and fifty dollars almost to
own the libs and make this video
what a [__] bonehead and that's why
this is why people are making fun of me
and he made a video after this which
he's like oh and this is like me burning
the Quran in Sweden people dude you know
what you missed wait wait you know what
you missed you missed his stupid Gene
Ken jacket you missed that you got to
put that on that oh yeah no no it's it's
in the video oh okay good yeah yeah I've
got to do this I just want to make sure
that that that the Ken yeah I got that I
got it there's no way he had that he
bought that over this I got the jean
jacket the white shirt and I also got a
little I heart Barbie pin
oh what a chucklehead that's why Ben
excuse me Barbie Shapiro yeah is on
bonehead of the week now we have Rudy
kaluti Grandpa farty maturity Rudy
Giuliani on the bonehead of the week why
did Rudy Giuliani make it on bonehead of
the week I mean I I'm sure there's a
hundred
ways that he could make it on the
bonehead of the week but I think it was
because he admitted to lying which yeah
yeah it's it's weird that he's like yeah
that one's a lie all those other ones
they're not like but that one that one I
have to say is a lie because I'm in
really big trouble with that live so I
gotta admit that I I'm a [__] liar
but you also see Republicans unwilling I
mean it's crazy because it's like look
though we knew that they were lying if
you look at the Dominion lawsuit right
the fact that they settled there you
look at the statements that were made
during Jan 6 right you had Rusty Bowers
who was like yeah
Rudy Giuliani came to us and we kept
asking for evidence he goes well I don't
really have evidence I've got
theories right I don't actually have any
proof to show you then you look at when
he attacked both of the Georgia poll
workers and it wasn't a thumb drive they
were handing it was a [__] gingerman
right and then you have him
and they're like oh they're still in the
election with tic tacs get the [__] out
of here and you you have you have this
moment where
you've now realized that everything that
he claimed during this election has been
alive but despite all of these actual
facts because facts don't care about
your feelings
they are unwilling to accept the truth
that Rudy Giuliani lied and he admitted
to line and I think a lot of them are
unwilling to accept the fact that Rudy
Giuliani most likely flipped on Donald
Trump in order to make this deal like he
had to admit to this to make sure that
he wasn't going to find himself right
well and I I postulated that the other
day when it came out I thought you know
what this is probably at the direction
of the special counts in Jack Smith
saying hey you got to undo this lawsuit
down there yeah you got to undo this
lawsuit so you can cooperate fully in
our investigation because if you don't
undo this lawsuit then you're not fully
you're not in good faith fully at you
know getting so he has to undo it and he
has to get to a settlement point and I
think that's what they're trying to do
but you you tweeted out something two
[__] years ago you said breaking Rudy
Giuliani says he's quote he said this
more than willing to go to jail
oh my God these people are so stupid and
you're wondering why Rudy Giuliani is on
the bone of the week and it's because of
a statement he made two years ago if the
American people want that and you said
two years later it's more true than ever
like he literally I'm more than willing
to go to jail
okay I mean whatever you want to do
that's on you dude I mean you got it all
right that sounds good I mean we'll do
that for you if you want
I'm sure Jack Smith will oblige yeah I
mean Jack Smith and his team are like
great you said this on this day uh all
right time to pay the piper and he's
like what and you know sweating ink ink
flowing down his head right I mean but I
do want to say as much as much uh
destructive influence Rudy Giuliani has
had I mean he has provided us with a ton
of comedic commentary and material yes
to roast him on right like no one will
ever forget Four Seasons Landscaping
right we'll ever forget the the ink
dying coming down his hair
or on top of the ink that's coming down
his face no one's ever going to forget
the fact that he wiped his nose
and then used it within the same moment
wiped his nose
and then wiped his face because he was
sweating profusely
oh and that was like within the same
like two week period right grandpa farty
makes you already always deliver this
great content uh rather he's he's he's
tucking his shirt into his balls on
Borat too or he's farting on Jenna Ellis
it never is uh it never is not a clown
show and it's gonna be sad when he
finally does go to prison because you
know it'll be less content that we have
it just be less content that we have you
know a Rudy content that is yeah
you know that happens speaking of
content why why is this [__] on
the alpha cook how did he get
Albuquerque was something did something
happen yesterday with Elon Musk so this
is from this week this might not be a
story that people uh followed but okay
what happened I was like that's such a
[__] cuck move all right by the way
everyone knows that the audience the
audience knows that Gabe Sanchez loves
Elon Musk it's one of his favorites
um so what happened was there was the
there was the like we're rebranding to X
right which the logo has changed at
least twice now
they don't even they can't even use the
name really honestly right so there's
this whole trademark so what people
don't realize too is back in 2012 I
think meta or the time Facebook had
acquired a ton of patents from
um oh my God from Microsoft okay and
they had patents there did they buy a
company did they buy like a shell
company that owned these paddles or
something I don't I think it was a shell
company it was just like that the
company owned them and they weren't
going to be using them so they came in
they're like look we know you have these
patents like you have the IP for the
stuff we want to buy the rights because
we're doing something similar right in
this so we'll we'll buy we'll just pay
you the money and a lot of these tech
companies you know to give you context
it's not just Facebook by like buying up
all these patents like that's why
Microsoft owns them that's why the
companies own them they trade patents
around they buy patents between each
other and [__] and because the
technology companies really trying to to
to have their market share so they want
to be able to be
um agile as you call but if you can't if
you can't secure a certain type of
branding it doesn't allow you to be as
agile as you want digitally right so
yeah so so it was it was AOL
Microsoft had acquired patents from AOL
because AOL went defunct right yeah they
[__] the bid exactly so when that
happened uh
Facebook came in and they bought about a
billion dollars worth of uh these
[__] things man it's I know but you
have to remember like what they're
planning back in 2012 they they've got a
road map and they're going to say well
we want to do these things who else is
similar to what we want to make in the
marketplace we want to go out and buy
these things and Microsoft who's not
doing anything with them I I don't think
at the time they had any sort of Social
Network application or were even
thinking of that do you think do you
think that's why it's so impressive that
uh meta and Instagram came with threads
so fast because I don't think that was
part of their plan like they weren't
like you know what we're going to
compete with Twitter like when Elon
bought it they're like oh hell yeah
we're gonna compete now I think I mean I
I would say it's kind of impressive
though how fast they got there yeah I
mean as as uh clunky as threads kind of
is because it is it's not as um it's not
as versatile as Twitter yet yeah and I
mean it's still it still is in its
infancy stages right right you have to
remember that yes they have patents they
have different types of of Technologies
they are available to them but we also
have to think back all the way to
October or so when Elon comes in with
the sink and he's like let that sink in
and take something right and along that
time from that point up until now meta
has been watching like what's going to
happen is he gonna rocket this thing to
the moon or is it gonna [__] blow it
up like his normal SpaceX Rockets
and what ended up happening is I'm sure
halfway through somebody's like look
with all these layoffs with all this
stuff happening all these people getting
canned and and advertisers leaving and
and a bunch of controversy around Nazis
and fascists and and right-wing in cells
I'm sure some was like look man
we can build a halfway decent product
here right do it and I don't I don't
know the actual facts but I'm sure when
before he even bought it is when meta
probably put a team together like hey we
need to we need to have our our wits
about us in case we can enter the market
and they probably dusted off some old
ass plan that they had to compete with
Twitter at some point that was half
built or some code that they were using
very similar type of technology and
right they're like well we have
something you can post
and then you can comment and engage with
and you can share and do all these other
actions so we just have to look at what
common modules we can bring over into
threads right and and make them work
together yeah one make it look similar
to the Twitter experience and really
honestly it was smart I mean on meta and
a lot of people want to give Zuckerberg
a lot of credit but to Zuckerberg's
credit I almost believe now like now to
see what happened in the last several
months that Zuckerberg really is smarter
than Elon like you know objectively yeah
as he's way smarter than Elon as bad as
uh
as much as you don't want to be on his
side I mean like he did an amazing thing
here right he brought a bunch of people
who were like oh man I don't [__]
like Facebook I quit Facebook I don't
like Zuckerberg he's the worst right I
have now caused people to be like what
is he the worst I mean right right in
the grand scheme of things when you're
comparing you know social media to
social media is there any real good ones
I mean even Jack is getting drawn you
know dragged through the mud with blue
sky and [__] yeah yeah and so the main
reason I brought it up because the alpha
cuck moment that sealed it for me was
yesterday I got confirmation that there
was an account this guy
um who had an account that was at X he
signed up very early on in 2007 at
Southwest so this so This Twitter
account has been uh it's been active it
has been highly active since 2007. right
the the account was at and then just X
okay
a lot of people were like oh man look
there's this account that exists out
there it's at X and this guy's like no
I've been using it this whole time right
that's me that's who I am I've had
people who have asked me if they could
buy it from me over the past you know
years and I've said no yeah I think at
one point he said he was offered like
fifty thousand dollars for at X right
because
so what ends up happening is
at one point two days ago the account
switches over
and now he no longer has access to that
account and if you already stole his
account Elon went in and stole the
account from the guy and they renamed it
now it's like at x a one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten right
that's what happened he stole the
account because Elon wanted it and you
want to know what he offered everyone
everyone was like oh my god dude this
guy probably made [__] bank he
probably got a ton of money for this 50
bucks no
he was offered X merch and to meet with
the management team
and the guy lives in SF wait wait wait
wait ex merch like a portion of the
profit are like literally here's a
t-shirt here's a here's a t-shirt like I
I had a Twitter account since 2007 and
all I got is this lousy t-shirt kind of
exactly so that's what so he got it
taken away from him yeah that's and they
support support emailed him and was like
hey would you like some merch some free
merch and would you like to meet the
management team no I want my [__]
account back [__] he's like no I don't
and this guy's you know he's a CEO of a
company it's called like orange photo or
orange
I don't think he can because I'm almost
certain that there's somewhere in terms
of services that's like hey I can take
this account if I want to because
Twitter technically owns it but also
it's not Twitter anymore it's X so X
could have at some point they they might
have known this was going to happen and
they're like we're going to write in
that we can now take any account that we
want
then on top of that oh Jesus there was
um
LeBron LeBron James's son bronnie yeah
he had uh cardiac arrest and everyone
was like oh my God it's because the
covet vaccine covet vaccine all this
disinformation and then Elon posted
myocardoitis
he gets community noted on it I think he
gets community notes and then
who gets to remove the community notes
well none other than the man who owns
the platform that makes the community
know so wait they Community known him
he's like nope don't like that getting
rid of it yep ah you talk about Free
Speech oh man he is he is a free speech
absolutist let me tell you what uh let
me see if I can I mean unless it's free
speech against him like with facts and
[__] why you know um um Sinead O'Connor
passed away yesterday 56 years old I
think she was yeah I I would probably
know some of her music but I I like I'm
you know admittedly I'm not a big fan I
would tell you if I was and I probably
would know music if I if I heard it but
here's the point is they were like as
soon as I say vaccine like oh my God and
I I postulated this morning I'm like
Jesus Christ these people are eventually
going to think that Michael Jackson died
of the vaccine
I mean they believe some of them believe
he's alive but they're gonna still are
they gonna so when the the Q Anon
conspiracies about
um and I I hear if you pull up the link
yeah what what what what's this here
this is the this is the community notes
and then this is the removed Community
notes oh so so this is the the
screenshots of them yeah because you
can't see the old one because so Elon
Elon says uh if you pull it up he goes
we cannot ascribe everything to the
vaccine and by the same token we not we
cannot ascribe nothing Mario kartotis is
a known side effect the only question is
whether it is a rare it is rare or
common or yeah common
then Community notes two different
studies or two different uh one from CBS
and one from Yale
[__] Elites
it says studies show the risk of
myocardos is significantly higher after
an actual coveted
uh
coveted infection than the vaccine
so after you get coveted right after
getting the vaccine for covid right
among adolescent boys the risk of
myocarditis is following a covet
infection was approximately twice the uh
the risk of following the second vaccine
dose which if I remember correctly I'm
pretty sure this was the same [__] that
Joe Rogan was trying to claim on his
podcast and then got fact checked in
real time right but it was unwilling to
accept but yeah but then actually the
CDC and the FDA said no we're not going
to give the boosters to this age group
of males because of this yes so like so
the idea is that oh it's the vaccine but
really honestly if you followed the
guidelines it's it's it's not and if you
follow the science covid would be worse
for this condition so it is possible it
is this condition because
Brawny had coveted I you know I don't
know what the case is I don't know I
don't know what his condition is I don't
know why he had the cardiac arrest they
don't either but here's the um here's
here's the removal of it so here's just
here's just the [__] just the Tweet
so he literally had it removed after the
fact what a piece of [__] yeah yeah of
course you know he got cucked by the way
you need to know when you when you own
the platform you get to do whatever you
want whether it's steal people's
accounts or you remove a fact check on
your disinformation perfect face for
Alpha cook too I got cut
[Music]
speaking of cucks apparently someone's
going to get cucked in DC maybe today
maybe today do you think it's going to
happen today or would it happen maybe on
next well prepare for it over the
weekend you know I I mean you know it's
hard to say I mean obviously the Trump
lawyers the news is that the Trump
lawyers have heard from the prosecutors
themselves the special counsel's office
that yes we are going to seek to indict
Donald Trump now when they'll get the
jury to actually vote on those
indictments to bring those indictments I
you know I I guess could be today could
be tomorrow could be late tomorrow could
be into the weekend but the thing is
it's going to be sealed so yeah we're
gonna have to wait for Donald Trump to
leak that he's been indicted by the
grand jury like literally that's what's
gonna have to happen remember we you
know uh we're we're coming up by the way
we're coming up on a year
the year anniversary
of Donald Trump telling us
that Mar-A-Lago was getting searched by
the FBI right he leaked that yeah that
was August 8th of 2022 Donald Trump went
online
posted about he I think he made a press
release they went through my [__] he's
like they raided the FBI illegally this
and that blah blah blah August 8th 2022
because I remember I was coming back
from a trip to Tech from Texas to uh
back to LA and I remember
Lee I think I was leaving I was in the
airport and I got I was like bing bing
bing and I was like what the hell's
going on and then I was like holy [__]
this is happening from
uh from his his Mar-A-Lago home and
Resort getting searched by the FBI but
at the time he's like it's a raid
they're coming after me and he made it
sound so dramatic well he's he's getting
Germanic this morning too uh because
here he is he says my attorneys have a
productive meeting a productive meeting
like this dude is begging with this he's
like please please don't [__] come
after me well and most people
um wouldn't want the doj to come after
him for I don't know trying to like
commit a coup like that wouldn't be a
thing that you'd I mean did he honestly
think did he honestly think that
the more he yelled about this and the
more well potentially incriminating
evidence that he presented before uh
Jack Smith and his team online for
everyone to see do you think that this
guy at one point was like God man if I
keep saying this stuff it's going to be
true and and they won't come after me
and I'll be totally fine yes I really
think he believes that [__] because
listen to this he says my attorneys had
a productive meeting what the [__] with
the doj this morning
explain in detail that I did nothing
wrong
was advised by many lawyers and that an
indictment of me
would only further destroy our country
oh all right well you're already
indicted in the country's still here
Demi yeah no indication of notice was
given during the meeting do not trust
the fake news on anything he's already
setting up hey when I leaked that I've
been indicted don't trust that news
no no listen Jack Smith if it is sealed
is not going to leak it he's not going
to and the reason why Jack Smith knows
he doesn't have to leak this [__] is
because Grandpa Poopypants the Cheeto
does cute and honor definitely 100 is
going to leak it to the media all's he
has to do is stay within his bounds and
his boundaries and tell Donald Trump's
attorneys what is happening and it will
filter down to [__] idiot Bill an
idiot no will [__] just send it into
the ether and and everyone will be like
Abigail again everybody go to Washington
yeah do that dummies do that do that I
mean this is gonna this is gonna be an
interest I I'm curious to see because
remember that you know there was the the
hush money payment in Manhattan there's
that one which a lot of people like ah
this is this is over overblown this is
this is not anything right here this is
this is totally legal payments and
they're trying to find whatever then
there's the document right and they're
like I don't know this also is nothing
because there's a presidential act and
he could totally be fine because he was
well within his right
now what people need to remember is that
this case this investigation right now
this what is you know has been dubbed
the Jan 6 investigation
is everything before January 6th it goes
all the way before the election
especially after election but before the
election when they're already putting
out there that they're not going to
accept the results then the election
happens and they're all meeting to
figure out exactly what they can do and
what they can say to fight it in court
to fight in the public opinion all of
these different things
so when people say Jan six I think I
think it does it a disservice because
people need to realize that it's
everything Jack Smith is is leaving no
stone unturned he is going for everyone
every single Eastman Giuliani
um you've got every single person in
this group that has had a finger on a
document
or made a phone call to someone else or
sent a text message or an email or
whatever it is
he's going all the way back because
that's not just January 6 or the days
leading up to January 6th it's the
months leading up to January 6th and
everyone who knew what was going to
happen and either didn't do anything
or helped bolster their ability or their
their their uh attempt at overturning
the election
so it's
I'm gonna be very interested to see who
else is charged with these indictments
or included in here because I'm sure
they're going to show the receipts like
they did with with the with the
documents case and I would love to hear
them try to argue this one
because I'm I'm gonna it's gonna be
interesting I wouldn't be surprised if
there's a a good fair amount of people
that are going to be included as names
in this stuff well meanwhile in Georgia
this is in Georgia they're putting up
barricades uh so it doesn't look like
we're on one indictment watch we're on a
couple indictment launches
um because they're already putting up
barricades there in Georgia because they
meet because the jury at least in the
is it the same for everywhere or is it
just for this case in uh with Jack Smith
because I know they meet Monday Tuesday
and Thursday
right well like a vote on again but they
also could have voted on it already
right right I mean this could already be
sealed and done yeah and and it could be
it's possible right I mean we don't know
we just we know what we know is what we
got but I mean could be
it could be different than what we think
it is meaning that it could already be
under seal uh I mean we could see that
but he's like it's been under sealed for
two months right but not only is who
else is going to be indicted because I'm
sure it's going to be John Eastman and
others but the thing I'm looking for is
those charges if seditious conspiracy
Works its way in
um because that is the pants [__]
there like literally and the other one
that can really scare the bejesus out of
Donald Trump is wire fraud uh for him
defrauding his supporters uh for legal
support when he knew that because that
was that was one that he went into or
that that Jack Smith was was like yeah
we'll take that on too right yeah we'll
look into that right so so I'm I'm
thinking I'm thinking that those are the
Char charges that I'm looking for if he
just gets like obstruction of a official
proceeding and I'm not saying that's not
significant I'm just saying that's not
quite as carries the weight
um in a in a federal courtroom or in a
federal prosecution like seditious
conspiracy yeah I'll be curious to see
because we know that obviously you know
Oath Keepers proud boys they've been
charged with this you know conspiracy of
sedition or seditious conspiracy
and now now after they've been charged
essentially in I guess holding I don't
know if they've like fully entered their
sentence yet but
the big question I have is for a lot of
these people you know they're going from
the little fish up to the medium up to
the big fish which is Donald Trump and
all of the people that were with him
so it does make me wonder for the people
that have been charged with seditious
conspiracy if they
after the fact
Arch in some way or did before this you
know some way
um
work with Jack Smith's team to be like
yep we actually this guy called this guy
and they called Roger Stone and Roger
Stone called us and you know like who
knows but I would be curious if that's
how they make the connection
um yeah so Donald Trump gets our
dishonorable mention because we're on
two indictment watches this week
double feature
our our winner you know they called the
uh um Barbie movie in Oppenheimer
barberheimer we should come up with some
kind of mixture of the Jack Smith
indictments and the The Fulton County d8
Bonnie Wilson Davis I don't know I'm
just saying you know because we're
watching both of them at the same time
it's kind of the same kind of the same
idea this is this is a summer
blockbuster baby it is it is well you
know it's hot out there and the content
is hot as well speaking of hot pieces of
garbage uh Greg Abbott Governor Greg
Abbott made his way on bone of the week
because he wants to drown women and
children uh so he's our winner this week
for bone end of the week because why not
put a [__] murderer who is a governor
who's violating human rights by killing
women and children in a river with snag
and drowns very Christian very pro-life
Tony yeah well the Republican Party
really holds up to those values that
they project onto others do I have some
Christian values I want to show you but
the first thing I want to show you is
how chip Roy this morning oh my God yeah
you double down oh my God you said
disgusting about this clip now this is
on oan and this is Chip Roy talking at a
press conference and of course he Ships
Ahoy Roy this guy look at look at the
diverse crowd behind him holy [__] look
at this a bunch of white dudes wanting
to kill Brown women and children yeah
Ronnie Johnson back there or Jackson
Jackson Jackson Jackson yeah I mean Bob
Johnson's a senator oh yeah he's an
alcoholic yeah yeah Ronnie he's a
congressman too but he's also an apple
oh yeah yeah I mean look they all look
the same right well they do look at them
they do look the same look at one of
these faces look at who's this guy with
the eyebrows and the beer and the bald
head up there I have no no no I don't
know I don't know
I have no idea but chip Roy here is the
Bold guy in the front
um we know chip Roy's one of the
insurrectionists um but let's let's
listen let's listen to chip Roy and his
empathy that he has for migrants
especially women and children crossing
the river getting caught in snagging
around so let's listen
we're gonna have to decide
as Texans what we're going to do about
it and I just want to be 100 clear I
stand behind Governor Abbott being as
aggressive as he needs to be to defend
the people of Texas period full stop
he has my full support
I will fight every inch of the way
against this federal government in terms
of what is happening to Texas oh my God
he wants to fight for the right to kill
women and children and drown him in the
river well thank you thank you chip Roy
boy you are a piece of [__] trash and
you thought and you thought this guy was
the bonehead of the week yeah
think about his capitulators and and
Chip Roy and all these other it's quite
a it's white dudes okay it's quite a
river to die in you know like
like God damn I mean to be like hey I'm
going to double down uh not only I mean
like he could have been like Hey look
there's better ways we could have done
it uh
uh or or this is the way no I know I
know I mean right right you could there
could be a million ways all these
different ways and he was like you know
what I'm gonna say drown these
[__] right
yeah just you know what I populated
earlier that Greg Abbott and the
Republicans are gonna say let's set up
snipers and let's just shoot them why
not I mean hey man what yeah I'm telling
I'm telling you man that you think chip
Roy here's saying this [__] about what
Greg Abbott is doing to women and
children and migrants crossing the river
you think we're too far off from these
[__] scumbags advocating for shooting
people with snipers coming across the
border or a river or I honestly don't
know this I'm sure I could find this in
a simple Google search but maybe someone
in the chat knows this are there such
things as River mines
what do you mean like like land mines oh
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah okay yeah they
put them in ports and [__] like for like
submarines and [__] oh yeah so I'm sure
they'd come up with some small see
that's the craziest part about this part
of the river where they have these buoys
is this is a small part of the river
where people cross because it's not that
[__] deep like you can walk across
you can walk across so they put these
buoys so you have to climb over them so
you get snagged which is the one word
and then it pulls you under so it drowns
you
I don't know I don't know how else to
[__] explain what is the purpose of
those things if not to snag a ground
yeah it it it it just seems like
there's no other way in which you would
use those things if not to hold
something underwater to not pass through
right it seems like it has very
malicious intent behind it and and also
Sinister and evil and vile
motives which is what you know what Greg
Abbott and Chips Ahoy Roy over here are
thinking like the fact that they're okay
with murder because you know what
they're brown and they're not American
so I don't give a [__] [__] about if
they die and that is what they believe
that is amazing these Republicans these
people who claim to be pro-life and you
gotta care after your neighbor and if
somebody does something then you only
love them even more if you doubt me that
they're gonna get there on some of this
stuff with these snipers and stuff
listen this is we show Duncan here uh on
another clip a couple days ago this
Christian hate preacher Duncan look at
this guy he looks like a he looks like a
a wish.com Matt Walsh if you can dream
that there is one he got rid of his suit
or his jacket that's good it must be hot
in there
um but anyways and he's talking about
lgbtq people and he's he's basically
saying that they're they deserve the
death Penal penalty so if you don't
think they're that far off with just hey
man just shoot them coming across the
border [__] them I don't know maybe this
is the new Christian Thea white
Christian nationalist theology that they
want but go ahead and listen I bet this
guy I bet this guy loves Greg Abbott for
what he's doing down at the river I just
want to point that out oh of course but
let's listen hey Leviticus 2013. if a
man also lie with mankind as eliaith
with the woman both of them have
committed an Abomination they shall
surely be put to death their blood shall
be upon them
you know what their blood should be upon
them means they're dead
they're they got their blood all upon
them because you just rocked them to
sleep
because they just threw a bunch of
stones at them until they died and
they're just bleeding all over them
their blood shall be upon them
why because that's a wicked sin in the
sight of God they deserve the death
penalty
they should be arrested the police
should arrest them
go to court
provide the evidence and then perform a
public execution
and then all the the nations would look
at this nation then there's no homos wow
that's a wise Nation I mean the world
should just be looking at Uganda right
now and be like man Uganda y'all know
what's going on
um whoosh so if you're what the [__] so
if you're wondering if you're wondering
if you're sitting there wondering if I'm
off track and I'm being crazy when I say
that these [__] idiots are gonna call
for for women and children to be shot
and killed while they're crossing the
border you're not paying attention I'm
trying to get you to pay attention but
you're not [__] paying attention to
what I'm telling you
you're just not
um here is a photo and it was sent you
you put it in the and the thing yeah
this is from Caitlin Caitlyn sent it to
me so yeah so thank you here's a photo
of them passing an infant through the
[__] bot the the razor wire on the
bank of the river they're passing a
infant through you know that that
murderer and rapist that little baby
that they're passing through the fence
there you know what I mean uh because
you know that little infant is a danger
to our American society you know it's
man it's
it's the same the children crowd that
think this is okay yeah yeah you know
what you know what speaking of the seed
the children crowd I might as well go
back here and show you another goddamn
clip I mean this doesn't end with these
[__] white Christian nationalists it
is amazing it is amazing that the lack
of self-awareness the the lack of
empathy the lack of just being a human
that they're willing to say oh you know
what we should do we should do how they
treat gay people in Uganda we should
kill these people because they don't
deserve to exist
uh I'm sorry where in the Bible does it
ever say that you should commit murder
because I'm almost certain I'm almost
certain there's like this thing with
like 10 it's like a list of 10 things
it's like uh Commandments and you're not
supposed to do one of them which is
[__] murder okay
so the the fact that they're like oh
yeah we should kill these people we
should get rid of the machine eliminate
them I was like okay fine I won't use
kill I'll say uh remove eliminate
exterminate like whatever it might be
the fact that they are okay with doing
this to a fellow human regardless of
where they are and who they are or where
they live and
whatever their beliefs might be
it's so anti-christian anti-jesus
it's an excuse because this is what it
is they use their religion as an excuse
for their own bigotry and xenophobia
well here's a good example congressman
John Rose he quotes God's children are
not for sale and he's posing with the
actor and uh producers of sound of
Freedom you see Kevin McCarthy's down
here talking about it too well what's
the guy's name Jesus here Jim Jim
Caviezel yeah Jim Caviezel this [__]
queuing on weirdo but John Rose John
Rose decided to go here's here's some
facts that Tennessee holler points out
about about representative Rose
representative Rhodes met his wife
pictured here pictured here when she was
a teenager are you following me she was
a child like God's children are not for
sale uh met her when she was a teenager
and he was in his let me let me check my
notes 40s in his 40s
he gave her a scholarship and then they
got married later on maybe you're not
the best messenger for this congressman
is what Tennessee holler says literally
the guy posing and saying save our
children literally groomed a child to be
a child bride I don't I I don't know how
to [__] I I try my best to show you
that's the same [__] this
[__] John John Rose here this
[__] would be like yeah he'd be
on chip Roy oh man he'd be like yeah
chip Roy you got that damn right drown
those [__] he'd be on the side
of Duncan like you goddamn right we
should execute all those homosexuals
like Uganda does that would make us a
world leader same [__] same
same [__] you're like we love
Jason Aldean who is that that sounds
pretty cool it's racist and [__] we like
that song yeah we like Jason same same
mother [__] yeah it's really it's
really something that they're that
they're able to again you know practice
being a Christian or a God-fearing uh
law abiding Christian and then and that
same in that same breath be like oh yeah
but those brown people or those people
South the Border or this person who
doesn't live here or is a born here
isn't real they don't exist they're not
a real citizen they're not a real human
they don't actually deserve anything
that we have to offer especially our
empathy and that's what leads us to the
winner of the bonehead of the week the
murderer of the week as we would want to
say here on the China
he's a goddamn murderer Governor Greg
Abbott you piece of [__] human trash
let's give him his do
[Music]
[Applause]
look Greg Abbott when you beat Barbie
Shapiro and Rudy's Rudy kaluti Grandpa
farty mccharty yeah and not even what do
you mean by that Jesus Christ
you're on the wrong side of his his
story boy you're on the wrong side of
History that's been bone of the week
stick around stick around we got a few
announcements coming up right after the
nice little jingle that everyone loves
bonehead of the week foreign
[Applause]
of the week I know it's not Friday it's
Thursday that's because tomorrow we're
not having a show I apologize it happens
it's happened this is I think the first
time it's happened that we couldn't
cover it yeah if there wasn't one person
on it then right yeah I said wait hold
on I just want to point something out I
saw someone in the comments I don't know
it was it was while we were talking yeah
somebody said how now how sparks now
does tiny hands what the [__] not cool
I'm gonna text Hal right now I don't
know I just I don't go off on that I
just I saw one thing so one thing in the
comments that said you know that said
something they weren't happy with Hal
doing little hands like we should try to
get you do to do like a like a like a
just to bust into his show to do the
tiny hands when he's doing them Health
specs what are you doing
that's hilarious that would be good
okay everyone we love this stuff
we love Hal here and we love the
sparklers who come here but maybe we
should start up like the tiny hand Feud
maybe we should do like a tiny hand Feud
and we should do like some silly ass
[__]
I got you now that's a good
collaboration that's a hell of a
collaboration maybe we should I'll I'll
see if I can get a hold of how and say
what the [__] is going on man with the
tiniest chick everybody check their
hands oh that's hilarious
that's the question does Hal Sparks have
the Cheeto Chuck that's what I want to
know does he have the Cheeto job he may
have dinians but does he have the Cheeto
chap does he have the tiny cheetah hands
oh that's hilarious rude
well uh maybe maybe we'll get a trend
going the tiny hand feud between uh our
show and Hal's no we we love how here we
love this part
sprinklers here and it would just be a
big joke but it would be kind of funny
so maybe maybe we should start the tiny
hand Feud maybe you should tweet at him
or something or someone should maybe
someone someone
should do it if as long as you present
Edwards
Edward are you listening
show me your hands oh that that's that's
one of the great uh cinematic moments in
history whether you watch the original
True Grit
remake
show me your hands you son of a [__]
so
maybe Hal Sparks should show his hands
yeah show your hands you son of a [__]
I'm Coming For You party hand off that's
hilarious
let's do it let's let's make it between
the [__] fam and the sparklers let's
make it a big ass joke that uh we're in
a big Feud over
um the use of tiny hands on her show
we're gonna have a tiny handoff so uh
everyone everyone get with it in house
chat tell them tell them we're super
pissed and did you see did you see what
they posted on Twitter about you copying
they want we're gonna have a tiny hands
cage match is what we're gonna do that's
what we're gonna do four hands enter
one or two hands leave I don't know have
hell on I would love to have hell on I
actually had believe it or not I had how
on I think for one or two of the Gen
January 6 select committee hearings I
had him on when we were doing this oh
yeah that's right I remember yeah he was
in like a round table thinking
afterwards or something yeah
um so we were in the discussion
afterwards so I or maybe one before or
something like that so yeah and I I know
how I've talked to Hal
um and we love the sparklers here I'm I
I I enjoy Hal's show I don't get to
watch it much because it's kind of on at
the same time as ours
um so he that's one reason why we're not
on each other's show everyone's like why
are you on his show why in the unusual
because we're like at the same time and
some people like why do you compete with
times we're not competing we're not
competing at all we're like saying the
same thing he likes that time I like the
time we've talked about it and we're
like I'm not gonna change it he's like
I'm not gonna change it either so we're
in a place where we agree to disagree
but what we can disagree about is this
goddamn tiny hands dispute you know what
I'm saying
very very bad very bad man rude excuse
me excuse me hell tiny hands okay who
did him first that's the question and
dance
I love it I love it so sparklers no it's
a big joke but maybe you can help out in
the effort too it's already I got you
the tiny not tagged on threads oh
there's no photo yet there's no photos
find a photo from his show and then pull
a photo from our show go ahead let's do
the tiny handoff let's do it let's get
this going Gunk on houseworks again
we're not gonna have a show tomorrow
we're back on Monday I promise I promise
same time same place on Monday but we
won't be here tomorrow but we will be
here on Monday on YouTube so don't
forget to subscribe right now to YouTube
and as you're leaving hit that like
button or if you didn't like the show
[__] you too
thumbs down excuse me excuse me this is
the greatest show ever ever dream ever
ever
huge
[Laughter]
ah you can also watch us on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels follow us over there
on Facebook at the Tony Michaels you can
tag me and Howl in the handoff over
there too also follow us on Twitch
actually I think I I think I did a raid
on Twitch to Hal's channel the other day
now I'm now I'm gonna really think about
this when I'm hand i'm tiny handing off
to Hell on Twitch so if you're rating on
Twitch make sure to go watch hell show
and make sure you get screenshots of him
using our tiny hands
because we're gonna have a hand off here
also download every single episode on
Apple Spotify and Google it's free 99
over there then Gusty a single dime you
should download it because it helps us
every time you download it helps us out
here on the Tony Michaels podcast
you got what was that coming this
weekend bro we don't I do I'm I gotta
what was that on the Barbie boom Barbie
Shapiro AKA bend down take down I'll
throw in a couple other Republicans and
what they did in their dumb [__] fake
outrage but Ben Shapiro is my main
target
because he just couldn't keep his
tiny hands off the Barbie movie and he
had to act like a fool act like a real
bonehead so go to add to go to
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez to check
out the newest episode
get your tiny hands on the newest
episode of what was that also while
you're on patreon check out my page the
Tony Michaels are doing a ton of stuff
with the Roundtable democracy I plan on
having one or two planning meetings this
weekend we're going to talk about Nick
O'Neal he's the found one of the
founders of fivecalls.org he may be
joining us to do a discussion on the
show and on the Roundtable democracy
giving us a more in-depth tour of his
website that we took a tour of the other
day also Jess Piper is going to come on
she wants to talk about education so we
need to as the patreon members we need
to do a little bit of planning so this
weekend we'll do some planning on the
Roundtable democracy on patreon.com Tony
Michaels that's patreon.com the Tony
Michaels and don't be afraid if you're
scared that you're not going to get to
see the Roundtable democracy discussions
don't worry all the actual workshops
we're gonna make them available on
YouTube publicly so don't worry there's
one already you know what I'll do I'll
tweet it out or send it out the link to
it so everyone can find it you find it
there on the socials I know it's
Thursday but it feels like Friday
because this is the last show of the
week tomorrow's Friday you got the day
off we got the day off we'll see you on
Monday same time same place have a safe
weekend surf sup [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon